Moving on to material optimizations. There are some really great
optimizations you can put into your materials, some nodes which you may not be familiar with, so hopefully we can
demonstrate something new today, but some material optimizations can give you a really good win in your project.
So the first thing you want to be doing is building parent materials that then you create
material instances from. So we won't be going over how to create material instances in this course.
There are other courses on material instances, however
just the concept of building a parent material that houses all the material instructions
that will be your main base material and then from that material you can right-click in your content browser
and convert and create a material instance from that parent material and therefore you can edit the individual
parameters of that parent material without recompiling the entire material. So for example if you made a
transparent glass material shader and then
you had a
parameter on that parent material called glass color for example.
You can then create multiple instances of that glass without
recompiling the parent material and you can change the glass color from green to a goldish
mustardy color
etc without
recompiling. So for your material pipelines
it's really good to get into the practice of having a parent material that houses
all the instructions that you need and then just
instancing off that parent material so that the majority of the materials in your map are actually
instanced materials rather than the parent material.
Moving on to some material switches
you can get a static bool in your material if you'd like so you can actually
decide to switch based on a given parameter here and then render the output so
you can edit these switches at runtime so you can actually call in this instance
be enable base color texture and if you enable that then it will turn green so maybe you might use this for an
optimization pass so you want to set everything to just render this luminous green
just to check what textures are being used where that might be a good use case for that. You can also get a static switch
which
has a similar similar effect so you know whether we're picking A or B we can still
enable this at runtime if we would like another good useful switch there
and then we can also get a mask switch so if you would just want to mask a certain channel
from a mask that you might have packed with RG and B
you can just mask based on a specific channel as well.
We have some quality expression nodes, so we've got a shading path, so do you want to change the
texture or whatever you might be inputting into this node
dependent on the the rendering model that you're using so especially if you're trying to work across multiple
platforms with maybe you've got deferred on by default and then you want to change it to a forward rendering
maybe for a VR application or you want a mobile application
you can change the shading path and therefore the instruction count of that material
based on the renderer that you're using
Again we can have a feature level switch so we could use these within the materials say you want these
different switches inside your game to say okay, I want to go at this level of detail for example for
SM5 and SM6. Okay, we'll set this and it's almost like
when we're using those texture groups and we were saying okay batch all these into this setting you can actually
decide on a
larger scale in your materials which
feature level you want to select
dependent on your texture quality you can say okay if we're running a
super low
texture quality or or even a high texture quality use this type of color if we're running on
medium or epic for example use this type of texture sample so
You know maybe the texture has been
imported a different
resolution maybe you want to make some affordances for the
Amount of information going in from a low quality switch to a higher quality switch
Yeah that that quality node is available for you there
And then also you you have a ray tracing quality switch, so if if you want to support
Real ray traced materials and non ray traced materials in the same project
But you want to make some affordances for someone that might not have ray tracing enabled then you can
Have different outputs based on whether ray tracing is enabled there